we have a never been seen before
dot TV
um this is coming out literally out
tonight yes there's one of the sketches
in it and any set up or you want to just
uh if Guy Fieri had PTSD
hello Terry vet but I'm also a grilled
meat connoisseur I went through hell and
back to defend this country now I'm
traveling all over it to find the best
greasy grub
when I was in War I went through a
pretty traumatic experience that left my
memory fragmented but my taste buds
perfectly intact whoa and sure sometimes
oh not cool
but I'll never forget these tasty
flavors so join me while I'm trying to
remember who I am with some
Unforgettable food I am the grill
sergeant
I'm here at rudo's hot house where I
hear he's got a spicy chicken dish
that's hotter than Napalm let's check it
out gang hey
good job [ __ ] hey I'll beat the [ __ ]
out of you I'll bust your ass boy
you don't [ __ ] with me
whoa whoa what's up guys I'm here with
Naruto and this is his world famous
spicy chicken
I'll tell you what Toby it's all about
the spices ain't that true brother back
in the military we used to have the same
this way
tell me about these spices rudo yeah uh
so we're just gonna slide in some uh
cornstarch right there that's cornstarch
and then a little bit of garlic powder
super important garlic powder
and then a little bit of a cinnamon
cinnamon yeah it's really good crazier
it is crazy it's really gonna make the
flavors explode
because if you do it with a machine it
might be too powdery it's not gonna fry
too
okay
you [ __ ] I just love the
crunchiness on the outside I Know What
You Did you son of a [ __ ]
I don't really like the tiny [ __ ] on the
walls that's why I don't wear my glasses
this chicken is unreal
[Music]
it's okay okay he's just having a
flashback he's doing great talk a little
bit more about the spices the cinnamon
that's a little goofy huh
you know what I love about this
restaurant they play a loud music in the
bathroom what the [ __ ] man
okay let's get back to the chicken can
you get back to the chicken
[Laughter]
wow that chicken's not half back
[Music]
whoa
[Music]
hey you can really taste that Center
you want a bag of ice yeah a bag of ice
might help you dig me up pretty good
back there haruto also the spices
getting into the wounds pretty bad
that's it for hero spicy chicken wow
that stuff had a kick coming up next
week we're headed to Denver to check out
Christ are you all right yeah I'm
driving around a convertible eating
[ __ ] and sandwiches
suck my dick
stop I mean you guys are [ __ ] great
yeah you're so [ __ ] great thanks man
I mean that thank you as much as I want
to just bash you right now thank you you
guys are [ __ ] great yeah that was uh
that was a good one that is and we
filmed that they were like there was old
people out on the in another restaurant
and like when we pulled up they were
everyone were like oh [ __ ] it's Guy
Fieri and like me walking in I was like
[ __ ] you [ __ ] they were all
like holy [ __ ] yeah it was pretty fun I
mean okay a couple things
first of all you're a very good actor
and I'm curious if you if you would do
dramatic yeah I've never done it do you
train at all did you aspire to do this
sketch yeah to do like in general yeah
yeah yeah definitely I yeah I feel like
you might be like a really like logo
like a sneaky really good actor okay
second of all the edit the edits
I thought you're gonna be like low-key I
think you're a little gay
no no no no dude you're not gay at all
dude no I'm not gay you're not
okay
acting's not gay yeah there's nothing
gay about it dude you're not happy
okay second of all uh the edit
you involved in the edit I hope no
John's
he's the one that's he's brilliant too
yeah I mean it's all that well film
sketches where I'm like is this even
funny this sucks and then he'll send me
the edit I'm like damn yeah the pacing
like jumping back between the girls and
then I noticed on this one I don't even
know if you did in the old ones as much
but you showed me another one as well
using the music
that's John it's [ __ ] yeah yeah and
we asked him to be here today but what
did he say he was too [ __ ] busy no he
has a job he's a day job come on John
yeah buy this thing so John can quit
please yeah this is we need John to quit
everybody at
home.tv I doubt he wants me to say isn't
it
filmmaking right yeah government yeah
yeah for a company
um but no it's just [ __ ] amazing and
it's like
it's just I've said this when it first
came out I said it when you guys were
originally doing it I know you [ __ ]
hate the compliments but I just want
people at home to to real I I think it's
the best sketch out now I don't know
anything else that I'm seeing that's
making me laugh consistently sleep cup
Tim Robinson oh dude sleep cop is great
[ __ ] I think you should leave Tim
Robbins
Tim Robbins Logan Paul recommended this
to you he's like dude this show next up
and he said I think you should leave and
then you he kept on going wait what do
you mean and you guys I think you should
leave it and then he could go on why
would you say that we had like a who's
on first moment I'm like buddy what's
happening right here why are you asking
me to leave
when I saw the Isis Toyota skit I
watched it mad late yeah and then I
texted you after I was I was [ __ ]
howling on my phone played it on my TV
for my wife and cousin who were visiting
and all of us were just like this is
incredible yeah thank you maybe this is
inside a baseball over comedy but I I
love I love kick it down comedy a bit
the um
the way that you write jokes and there
are other people who are like this like
the way Chappelle writes jokes is sketch
like if you see like one of his bits you
can also like
it comes almost with visuals yeah and I
remember jokes I think you said that
yeah maybe and we did it well well the
one joke you saw me do a joke at the
seller it was so that's just a sketch
yeah like it wasn't even a joke you were
pitching it I think you were either just
a sketch I don't want to give it away
can we tell the premise the premise
you've seen the joke it's yeah it's at
the beginning of my special yes uh yeah
the guy's coming up with age of consent
yeah the guy having to guess so funny as
soon as I said it yeah he was like
that's a sketch yeah that's why we used
it at the beginning of the special game
it's kind of just a standalone joke like
it doesn't have anything to do with yeah
you know what I mean yeah
you know yeah yeah
see what happens when we just say how
great you are yeah
but this is good would you ever do your
version of Chappelle Show yeah like
stand up into sketch yeah stand up back
and forth yeah I'd like to do that I
think I might be yeah that's kind of
what you're doing now right if somebody
gave us more money are there elements of
this you make that could you do it on a
small version and then just build it up
on YouTube yeah I think so let's do it
at a club the hard part is the rest of
the guys like if we put this out for
free I get to make money because I get
to go tour with it yeah yeah what are
the results in ticket sales they get
nothing so when you say you had to put
this fine to pay well but when you said
you paid 270 are you also paying them
out of that or are you waiting they got
some okay yeah they got some yeah yeah
but yeah interesting Cuisine choice on
this sketch Cuisine yeah
[Laughter]
yeah yeah which that was tough to film
I've Never filmed a fight scene with a
stranger it's very uncomfortable I
thought he meant to wrestle for like an
hour really yeah that's really
uncomfortable you rubbed his hair I
grabbed his head but he was like go hard
and I was like don't go hard stuff this
is Dave Goggins
go hard in between every scene I'd be
looking back at the like John and them
filming like dude [ __ ] hurry this up
yeah you know I also noticed how long
ago did you film this
is this in the middle of like stopping
it was kind of it was starting
relatively you did it yeah yeah
well I'm gonna say what I noticed uh SNL
and all these shows pushed so much for
diversity but your sketches are always
just naturally and not in like a weird
Force way they just are diverse you know
what I mean like they got the so many
sketches with Reggie Reggie Conquest
who's so funny and like you know what I
mean I think you actually just do a lot
of jobs in a couple who's aunt more you
know he's at the cellar Anthony Moore oh
yeah yeah that's great yeah yeah yeah so
it seems like honey yeah yeah it goes by
it yeah I've never I've never called a
man eight more you gotta check him out
check him out hey check him out I know
him bro
[Laughter]
it feels weird when someone points you
like that right like this yeah yeah whoa
dude that was crazy dude you're so tough